hi my name is Brandon Hancock I'm one of
the co-founders and head of Technology
at snorkel AI
yeah well foundation models are a super
exciting development in AI but for most
high value Enterprise use cases they're
not ready to use out of the box without
some amount of adaptation so circle flow
is a a platform for adapting these
models making them higher quality doing
so with programmatic labeling and we use
these models heavily in the platform
which hugging face as the largest most
comprehensive provider of these models
is very important for us to integrate
and partner with so that our customers
can build on those models you know in
circle flow
so large and relatively difficult to run
and maintain many of our customers don't
have that ability to run it on their own
Hardware so having the ability to tap
into and utilize these models without
having to run it themselves was a big
unlock for them and that's what you know
hugging face inference endpoints
provides and initially there was a
challenge around only a limited number
of models being able to be made
available because a server had to be up
and running for each model we wanted to
have access for but now that we can
pause and resume endpoints it can be
obviously a lot more efficient since all
these models can have their own
dedicated endpoints that we spin up when
they're needed and spin down when
they're not
yeah we were pleasantly surprised to see
how uh just straightforward it was to
set up all of the configuration options
pretty self-explanatory but also had
access to all the options we needed in
terms of what cloud to run on what
security level we needed Etc
space is Super Active right now with
lots of additional models coming out all
the time so we moving forward fully
expect a hug and face to continue to be
a leader in making these open source
models available and then snorkel flow
continuing to be a platform that allows
all of our customers to to build on
those and apply them to their high value
Enterprise use cases
foreign